we should say upfront that we firmly
believe the dark Knight's Joker to be a
raving sociopath and an absolute Menace
to Society but hear us out it's
sometimes hard to argue with his
philosophy that human beings are not
meant to be confined within a structured
society and yes human beings find ways
to remind us of the delicate nature of
social contracts every day Joker's fairy
versus fairy experiment may have failed
to bring Gotham to its knees but that
doesn't mean he wasn't right about a
certain gothamites nature yep we're
talking about about da Harvey Dent
better known as Toof face Joker tortured
the noble lawmen emotionally and
physically early in the film before
breaking Dent psyche and turning him
loose on a coin flipping Killing Spree
bringing Gotham's Golden Boy down into
the trenches with the rest of the city's
criminals was Joker's Masterpiece